[Musique]
bonjour La voix est Libre en direct tous
les samedis sur France 3 avec
aujourd'hui quatre voix pour commenter
une voix celle du président de la
République François Hollande qui a tenu
jeudi la 5e conférence de presse de son
quinquena la première après les
tragiques événements de janvier il a
fait un certain nombre d'annonces et
pour en débattre autour de cette table
nous nous accueillons la socialiste
Fadila catabi bonjour bonjour vous êtes
vice-présidente du conseil régional Rémy
del lat député UMP de la Côte d'Or
bonjour Rémy DEAT bonjour Alain Raymond
responsable du Front de Gauche dans
lyonneour bonjour à vous et Christian
lonet bonjour vous êtes le président du
groupe Front National au conseil
régional et comme d'habitude chez vous
bonjour à vous pardon Christian Launet
chez vous vous pouvez ajouter votre voix
à ce débat sur Internet et sur les
réseaux sociaux d'abord la tonalité
générale de cette conférence de presse
avec un rendez-vous marqué la presse l'a
beaucoup dit par un thème de cohésion
sociale on est dans la suite des
attentats des grandes manifestations
puis des réflexions sur l'état de la
société française avec ce mot d'aparte
qu'a proncé manuel Vals Fadila catabi
c'est une vraie demande des Français la
cohésion sociale ou c'est un thème
porteur pour un président de la
République je dirais que c'est à la fois
porteur et c'est aussi une demande des
Français au vu des de la situation
dramatique que notre a traversé au mois
de janvier on a vu effectivement qu'il y
avait une forte mobilisation des
Français il y a eu un sursaut
républicain quand effectivement les
valeurs de notre société les valeurs de
la République ont été mises à mal et
donc il y a une vraie attente et
d'autant plus que là avec les attentat
je veux dire que on a touché la France
au cœur de ses valeurs et donc là on
voit bien qu'il y a eu une forte
mobilisation REM de Lat oui la la
cohésion sociale effectivement a été une
très belle dém stration de ce que l'on
attendait après les tragiques événements
du mois de janvier ça fait un mois jour
pour jour c'est aujourdh un mois jour
pour jour pour autant faut-il se poser
la question aujourd'hui le président de
la République parle souvent de l'esprit
républicain mais qu'est-ce que c'est
l'esprit républicain qu'est-ce que c'est
que la République la République c'est
déjà des lois des lois que l'on applique
partout que l'on applique que tout le
monde doit impliquer et que l'État doit
faire respecter avec beaucoup de fermeté
beaucoup d'autorité aujourd'hui c'est ça
que les Français attendent et je suis à
tout le moins surpris de voir que au
contraire le Gouvernement sur ce point
ne nous a pas rassuré depuis le 7
Janvier ne nous a pas rassuré parce que
quand je vois que Madame tobira qui a
pris des mesures au niveau de la
réforme au niveau de de la justice qui
vont à l'encontre de ce que l'on attend
en matière de fermeté et de respect de
de la République ça c'est c'est un
élément
tout à fait important 2uxème élément le
président de la République souhaite une
cohésion tant mieux il a plutôt réussi
l'exercice du du 11 janvier mais
derrière qu'est-ce qui s'est passé à
quel moment a-t-il consulté les
formations de notre pays formation
politique de l'opposition et pour
proposer faire des propositions qui
demain concrètement feront que l'on
reviendra à une situation qui permettra
d'éviter ce que nous avons connu alors
aujourd'hui il nous propose dans dans sa
conférence de presse vous observerez
d'ailleurs que c'est la troisème fois
déjà qui parle depuis le début de
l'année 3è fois pour nous dire et ben
écoutez il y a des choses qui vont pas
il faut qu'on réforme l'école mais
a-t-il oublié qu'il y a pas si longtemps
nous avons eu une loi qui s'appelle
refondation de de l'école il dit
aujourd'hui il a un problème de logement
en France il a raison moins 10 % de
construction en 2014 et un vrai problème
de de peuplement de au niveau de de la
politique de la ville d'une manière
général mais a-t-il oublié qu'il a fait
la loi allure la loi allure qui va à
l'encontre de ce que vous êt train de
faire le sommaire de cette émission réy
de je suis pas en train de faire le
sommaire mais je crois que voilà c'est
un tout et voilà voilà donc ça vous a
pas forcément ça vous a pas forcément
satisfait Christian lunet application
des lois d'émi DEAT cohésion sociale
aussi bien évidemment c'est une une
nécessité nationale mais si vous voulez
après les événements effec à laquelle
vous n'avez pas vous Front national
souhaité prendre part une phase bon
c'est c'est peut-être plus plus
compliqué on a on a on a été choqué
comme l'ensemble des Français par par
ces événements tragiques mais et la
cohésion nationale sociale s'impose
comme une nécessité nationale mais après
effectivement après ces événements
tragiques et et les difficultés
auxquelles sont confrontés
quotidiennement les les Français on
pouvait s'attendre lors de cette
conférence de presse si vous voulez
concernant la cohésion sociale également
bien bien évidemment des annonces fortes
mais aussi sur la sécurité sur sur
l'emploi sur l'école sur le service
national en fait pas grand-chose
pratiquement rien il y a eu une des
incantations enfin finalement François
Hollande est resté fidèle à lui-même des
vœux
pieux sans perspective sans perspective
précis sans objectifs clair c'est du
réchauffé c'est très décevant à la r Oui
euh cohésion sociale si on lance ça bien
évidemment tout le monde est d'accord
hein tout le monde veut que on s'entende
bien entre ce entre nous tous seulement
comment peut-on faire de la cohésion
sociale dans un pays où il y a bientôt
toute catégorie confondu 6 millions de
chômeurs quand les territoires sont
laissés à l'abandon dans pas mal de
régions quand effectivement il y a une
crise du logement depuis des années et
que on fait des vux pieux aujourd'hui on
dit il faut créer et cetera il faut
obliger les M a appliquer la loi SRU
mais ça fait 20 ans qu'on dit qu'il faut
l'appliquer quand on sait l'état dans
lequel se trouve l'éducation national
aujourd'hui avec des enseignants à qui
on demande de tout régler les problèmes
mais qu'à côté on on laisse par exemple
disparaître des postes de travailleurs
sociaux qui sont dans les rues pour
aider justement tous ces jeunes-là en
desérrances quand on nous dit quand le
Président nous dit les associations on
doit pas assécher les budgets des
associations quand les mairies en ce
moment sont en train justement de
baisser les les subventions aux
associations près d'un million sans
doute bientôt au budget pour la seule
ville d'osser alors il annonce il fait
un show c'est de la communication qu'il
a fait moi pour moi c'est pas une
conférence de presse il a fait il paraît
qu'il a un nouveau conseiller en
communication ça marche très bien
effectivement alors il surf
effectivement sur la vague légitime sur
le la l'indignation légitime sur la
défense des libertés qui qui a eu lieu
avec plus 4000 mil de personnes et tous
les Français qui étaient effectivement
dans le désarroi dans la colère et dans
l'alignation et cela ça a eu lieu c'est
très bien mais demander aujourd'hui
l'unité nationale quand tout est fait
pour diviser quand on veut diviser
certains les communautés quand on veut
une France des communauté alors que
c'est une France de la nation de la
Nation Unies qu'il faudrait avoir et
qu'on veut diviser ses communiqués ses
communautés pour les mettre les unes en
face des autres et qu'elles s'affrontent
et bien on ne peut pas parler on
souhaite l'unité nationale que il y a
une volonté de faire s'affronter les
communautés parce que c'est c'est ça
écoutez moi quand j'entends le discours
du FN c'est bien les communautés et on
va demain en faire partir un paquet si
jamais il venait au pouvoir c'est bien
effectivement se faire faire s'affronter
des communautés comment ça s'appelle
autrement ça ça appelle une réponse de
CH Oui c'est c'est c'est facile d' de
d'agiter le chiffon rouge pour faire
peur nous si vous voulez si si si si on
a on a la comment diraisje nous le
l'obsession de la de du respect et de
l'amour de la France et effectivement
ces événements tragiques il faut il faut
il faut punir les coupables c'est
évident mais nous nous identifions
également les responsables et les
responsables de ces de cette incohésion
sociale c'est effectivement les
responsables politiques de droite comme
de gauche qui depuis 30 ans ont fait ont
favorisé une immigration massive dans
notre pays entre
entre 8 et 10 millions de personnes de
confession musulman entre 8 et 10
millions et donc c'est c'est un c'est un
crime c'est une c'est c'est de la non
assistance à peuple en danger et c'est
un crime contre la cohésion sociale
parce que le résultat que vous le
vouliez ou non et bien c'est un
communautarisme sur lequel c'est un
terrro sur lequel se c'est une France
riche de de sa diversité écoutez vous
direz ça au aux premier aux électeurs
qui ont voté massivement pour le Front
national vous
Tromp ri de t'a demandé Fab ch tout
ce
suite permettez-moi de dire que que je
regrette la tournure que prend notre
débat voilà exactement ce que nous ne
voulons plus en France oui je crois que
au contraire la France a toujours été
une terre d'accueil et elle doit le
rester dans dans le respect de de ses
valeurs de ce qu'elle représente de ses
racines de sa cultureadiction d'origine
chrétienne qu'il faut pas perdre de vue
pour autant on ne peut pas porter de de
jugement à l'égard de de personnes qui
sont venues qui sont immigré et que nous
accueillons et quand nous avons nous
quand nous avons nous en 2007 fait la
loi sur l'immigration la loi heurtefeu
nous avons eu cette volonté de pouvoir
accueillir des personnes dignement ça
veut dire quoi accueillir des personnes
dignements et ça relève de ce que nous
recherchons dans la cohésion sociale
c'est de leur permettre déjà d'avoir un
accueil qui leur permette de vivre
décemment c'estàd un travail un toit et
pouvoir ainsi s'insérer dans la
pardonnez-moi r mais le ministère a été
estampillé identité nationale à un
moment donné est-ce que c'était pas au
un signal qui allait dans un autre sens
ben je crois que c'est une
interprétation que vous pouvez faire
mais peut-être est-ce que c'est pas ça
qui manque aujourd'hui cette référence à
la France au fond nous sommes fiers
d'être français et et nous sommes fiers
que la France est et au contraire cette
volonté de pouvoir accueillir de pouvoir
tendre la main et c'est c'est tout le
principe de l'organisation de de notre
ré toute la dimension aussi de la
cohésion sociale qu'on évoquevent et
parfois je suis inquiet je partage
certains avis qui viennent d'être émis
je suis inquiet sur cette cohésion qui
est mise à mal le président de la
République pas absurde je un thème le
président de la République a fait voter
en février 2014 donc il y a à peine un
an une loi sur la cohésion sociale vous
avez observé que jeudi dernier il a dit
qu'il fallait faire une nouvelle loi
c'est quand même assez paradoxal je
rejoins ce que j'ai dit juste avant sur
le logement je rejoins juste avant ce
que j'ai dit sur l'école quand vous
pensez quand même que les résultats de
cette politique souhaitée par le
gouvernement ça a été de remettre en
cause le enfin le le le réseau
d'éducation prioritaire pour les grésill
c'est un signe
malheureux je dois dire que grâce à mon
intervention pas vous la grâce à mon
intervention madame pardonnez-moi grâce
à mon
intervention de prendre la parole
monsieur
lesisso TER je vais vous
écter grâce à mon intervention à celle
d'autres élus madame la ministre Najat
Belkassem a accepté effectivement que
les GR redevienne un réseau d'éducation
prioritaire mais nous nous sommes battus
pour ça quelle image on donne quelle
image on donne vre de commissariat de
poli monsieurputé je ne peux pas vous
laisser dire cela je ne peux pas vous
laisser dire cela qui a mis à mal
l'école de la République qui a mis je
vous pose la question monsieur le député
qui nous ouvre le thème de l'école allez
bien sûr l'école indispensable elle est
au cœur est elle est au cœur elle est au
cœur des priorités gouvernementales avec
la jeunesse écoutez pour siéger déjà
depuis de nombreuses années au conseil
régional donc depuis 2004 nous avons
assisté entre 2002 et 2012
systématiquement à un écrémage de
nombreux postes ont été supprimé
vraiment l'école a été mise à mal avec
tout ce qui est tous les accompagnements
les soutiens tout a était vraiment mise
à mal et au lieu de mettre les moyens là
où justement comme vous le disiez tout à
l'heure dans certains quartiers et
cetera on on était que dans une dans une
dynamique comptable il fallait rendre
des comptes et rendre des postes et
aujourd'hui effectivement le
gouvernement a pris la mesure à la
hauteur des enjeux en disant l'école
doit être au cœur de l'action
effectivement aujourd'hui on peut pas
tout attendre non plus de l'école hein
les enseignants font déjà un travail
formidable c'est très compliqué il faut
aussi que les parents puissent entrer
dans les écoles parce qu'ils ont aussi
leur mot à dire mais l'école ne peut pas
répondre à tout donc première chose donc
vous êtes mal placé pour parler de
l'école alors qu'il y a eu un écrémage
depuis des années des années à la fois
sous SAR question de de nombre de postes
les 60000 postes créés dans l'éducation
nationale les quti ne referons pas
demain une école écoutez monsieur prof
quand il était maire à Dijon il a fait
véritablement une véritable politique de
mixité sociale et il l'a réussi et le
quartier des grés sil est ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui c'est grâce à la vol
politique de certains hommes politiques
et j'espère que vous monsieur le député
ma puisque vous êtes maire j'espère que
vous pratiquez également cette mixité au
sein au sein de votre ville or vous
n'atteignez pas vous ne respectez même
pas la loi et ses rues concernant la
construction de logements sociaux donc
vous êtes mal
placépondreis après on passera un autre
thème parce qu'on avait prévu plein ce
thème de l'enseignement et de l'école
quand même extraordinaire aujourd'hui de
voir et François Hollande l'a répété
qu'il fallait par exemple je prendre
qu'un exemple parce que là on pourrait
rester une heure là-dessus valoriser
défendre la formation professionnelle
oui et bien dans le même temps par
exemple on ferme un lycée professionnel
àgène et qui le ferme le recteur
représentant du gouvernement du ministre
de l'éducation nationale et monsieur le
Président patria président de la Région
voilà ce qu'on
fait vous savez qu' un certain nombre de
raisons très
particulièr il y a rien de particulier
il y a une ville il y a un lycée il doit
il doit exister et les parents se
battent làdessus non non vous pouvez pas
me laisser excusez-moi je pas
jeisend sur l'ignement il ne suffira pas
de toute façon parce que les 60000
postes j'attends toujours quand même
qu'ils arrivent jusqu'à la fin du mandat
il ne se fera pas de mettre des
enseignants où en eston de la
formation o eston de la formation des
enseignants il y a plus de formation des
enseignants elle est morte la formation
des enseignants aujourd'hui on a tout
détruit ces 10 20 dernières années que
ce soit la droite ou le elle a été
remise en place si j'ai bien compris
dans les universités demand
demand demander à tous les formateurs de
de de ces ex FM ce qu'il en est
aujourd'hui j'en connais
quelquesun on passera je peux répondre
sur Lyc migène quand même j'ai accueilli
justement toute la délégation consil
régional on vous fait voilà on a fait un
retour effectivement il y a eu donc cet
incendie et il est normal qu'à un moment
donné on se pose les questions c'est un
petit lycée il y a 170 élèves exactement
on se pose la question aujourd'hui quand
on fait de la formation aussi c'est bien
sûr la transmission des savoirs de la
connaissance et cetera mais aussi en
terme d' d'employabilité vous allez voir
le BDF qui vous dit il y a pas de
F les conseils régionaux aussi
aujourd'hui monsieur les conseils
régionaux sont responsables de la carte
des formation et quand on fait des
ouvertures de formation ou des
fermetures on tient en compte on prend
en compte pardon les besoins d'un
territoire les besoins économiques et
bien
s BES parce que la formation des
microtechniques va finir dans les pour
le méill alors je vous propose qu'on
fasse pas un débat sur uniquement la
formation professionnelle et qu'on
redonne la parole à Christian lonet qui
attend de répondre sur merci sur l'école
effectivement le décrochage scolaire
c'est un fléau
national c'est c'est une indignité
nationale donc François Hollande
souhaite une grande école du numérique
et la une formation des enseignants
après que cgolen Royal est souhaitaer
donc faire de tous les élèves des éco
citoyens enfin les les enseignants
croulent sous les cons signe ils le
disent ils s'en plaignent il faut qu'ils
instruisent la le la la sécurité
routière la
laïcité le bien vivre le développement
durable tout ça donc c'est ça crée cré
le résultat 180000 enfants décroche euh
par
an
écrire le Front national à la place des
gens qui décident actuellement mettrait
beaucoup plus de moyens sur l'école non
l'école est au cœur de la de la rép mais
il faut de l'argent on parle de Budet
l'école est au cœur de la République il
faut redonner d'abord du sens à la
responsabilité des parents ce sont les
parents qui sont en charge de
l'éducation des enfants puis ensuite il
faut resituer le cœur de métier de
l'école qui est l'instruction publique
mais là il faut sortir du du pédagogisme
franc-maçon et de toutes les et de tout
et de tous les délires et de tous les
délires pédagogiques pour redonner du
sens aux méthodes traditionnelles de
d'enseignement non mais si c'est une
réalité méthode traditionnelle
d'enseignement du français de la lecture
la méthode syabique l'enseignement de
l'histoire chronologique l'enseignement
classique et puis et et je conclus si
vous me permettez il faut remettre au
cœur de l'école de deux mots il faut que
ces deux mots règnant en maître
c'est-à-dire la la la discipline et
l'autorité et la
laité est-ce que vous y mettez laïité
bien s bien s je vous
propose la laïcité bien sûr pour qu'elle
soit pour qu'elle soit aussi bien
comprise il faut impérativement qu'elle
soit bien appris et ça n'est pas encore
aujourd'hui d'actualité bien expliqué
voilà parce que la non mais je termine
du coup ces hommes
pr la laité c'est un point intéressant
donc c'est non je disais donc c'était
important aussi qu'elle soit bien
comprise parce que très souvent elle est
prise plutôt comme une attaque vis-à-vis
de telle ou telle religion et pour ne
pas citer vis-à-vis de l'islam très
souvent c'est très mal perçu donc il
faut aussi qu'elle soit bien comprise et
bien enseigné mais alors différ parce
que beaucoup non mais quand on entend
certains propos généralement c'est
plutôt par même temps les enseignants
ils ont les enseignants ils ont pas
attendu 2015 pour parler de laïcité dans
les classes on va pas non plus se
réveiller comme ça un matin pour autant
manifestement ça a pas l'air de
fonctionner ou ça a l'air compliqué à
certains endroits et il suffit pas de
dire faire autrement c'est stigtisation
dans la césion sociale on en parle on en
parle mais je veux dire les débats sous
Nicolas Sarkozi c'était plutôt des
débats qui stigmatisaent qui divisait la
société on peut en parler bien sûr on
peut parler des problèm
problèmes des difficultés et C mais
quand on entend parler par exemple quand
les jeunes issus de l'immigration qu'on
dit encore issu de l'immigration ils ont
besoin d'être intégrés quelle
intégration ce sont les enfants de la
République donc il y a pas de problème
d'intégration il y a des problèmes
sociaux il y a des problèmes économiques
et ces jeunes qu'on dit ils ont besoin
de s'intégrer non que demandent-ils ces
jeunes un emploi une formation de
qualité un logement donc ça suffit avec
ces discours NAS et à bond et là
aujourd'hui la le président de l'UMP il
se prend le pied dans le tapis parce
qu'à force de courir après le Fond
national du coup la la droite
aujourd'hui l'UMP aujourd'hui est
divisée donc à un moment donné
effectivement il faut se poser les
questions et les vrais problèmes et en
parler de manière sereine sans
stigmatiser telle ou telle personne me
Volz pas mon dernier sujet sur l'UMP
tout de suitez madame kadabi vous avez
Plô sur ce point de la laoui vous avez
plutôt une approche assez particulière
de la laïcité ah bon quand vous parlez
de la Laté vous ne parlez que des
musulmans c'est plutôt assez paradoxal
non la laïcité c'est tout l'inverse la
laïcité c'est le respect de toutes les
confessions toutes
confessions la laïcité ça veut pas dire
on ignore toutes les confessions au
contraire mais on a le respect pour
chacun de croire de ne pas croire et ça
c'est ça qui est fondamental dans notre
République et c'est ça qu'effectivement
il faut remettre au goût du jour à
l'école et et je crois que le rôle de
l'école on a on a entendu autour de ce
plateau que l'école en fait elle
réussira le jour où elle aura plus moy
plus professeur c'est tout l'inverse ce
qu'il faut c'est aujourd'hui redonner
vraiment la capacité aux enseignants par
leur formation par leur
rémunération
pasette semain alors là qui invente des
choses que j'avais jamais vu dans laité
la laité c'est vraiment le principe
actif de la
République oui bien s
fa adérer à tout ça et
je est mal les jeunes ne la comprennent
pas donc il faut bien un moment donné
faire de
pédagogieexlication
Ch on parle beaucoup de l'école sur la
lacité est-ce qu'il a pas aussi à la
République à affirmer réaffirmer un
certain nombre de principes si je puis
me permettre on parle là de ce qui s'est
passé depuis le début janvier on va se
souvenir qu'il y a eu par rapport à la
religion aussi un certain nombre
d'événements en particulier la manif
pour tous qui a été très présente au
moment du mariage pour tous on le sait
avec des groupes depression religieux
extrêmement présents dans cette manif
pour tous à ce moment-là est-ce que il y
a pas différents points qui ont attaqué
le principe de laïcité en France ces
derniers temps on se souvient aussi des
polémiques à l'école sur la théorie du
genre en réalité est-ce que le problème
est pas extrêmement profond dans notre
pays est-ce que la laïcité est pas
totalement passé au second
maisité la laïcité n'exclut pas pour
autant le le débat y compris
l'intervention des des
confessions vous avez cité plusieurs
exemples pour lesquels je crois qu'au
contraire il était normal que que les
confession puissent exprimer le leur
opinion ne serait-ce que pour tout
simplement que que tout à chacun puisse
comprendre se faire sa propre opinion
vous avez parlé du mariage pour tous je
crois naturel que plusieurs confessions
les trois grandes confessions monothéist
ont pris des positions très claires qui
se rejoignaient d'ailleurs je dois le
dire pour autant on peut pas on peut pas
considérer que c'est ce sont les les
confessions qui ont conduit les
manifestations d'opposition ou les
prises de position républicaine je crois
qu'il faut pas mélanger on a on a une
contribution per il y a eu beaucoup
d'événements qui montrent queme une
partie de l'église catholique s'est
beaucoup occupée d'organiser la
protestation républicaine pour le coup
aire moi comme parlementaire au moment
de de la loi du sur le le mariage pour
tous je puis vous dire que j'ai
participé à des groupes de travail qui
ont entendu l'ensemble des confessions
qui souhaitaent donner leur opinion je
n'ai pas je n'ai pas je crois pas eu à
n'entendre que la religion catholique et
et c'est tout naturel on a entendu les
les imams on a entendu
effectivement vous coupe parce que je
regarde le temps qui passe et il y a un
point quand même que tout le monde
attendait il nous reste 5 minutes dans
la première partie de cette émission
c'était un service civique ou un service
militaire euh on va dire que les les
nostalgiques du service militaire sont
revenus à la charge en disant que s'il y
avait des problèmes de cohésion sociale
en France c'était parce qu'il y avait
plus de service militaire finalement
François Hollande a annoncé on va dire
l'extension à tous ceux qu'il souhaitait
d'un service CIVI euh non donc non
obligatoire euh est-ce que ça vous
semble une une réponse à ce qui s'est
passé oui bien bien sûr vous allez me
dire qu est la position du Front
National et est-ce que est-ce qu'en plus
il y a pas un vrai danger dans ces
services civiques d'aller sur des
terrains comme l'aide aux personnes et
des choses comme ça qui sont des
gisements d'emploi Fadil catabi non il y
a pas de danger c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
le gouvernement non il a mis sur la
table un certain nombre de dispositifs à
destination des jeunes alors bien sûr il
y a l'école il y a l'apprentissage aussi
on en parle pas donc l'objectif d'AT
500000 en fait elle
voudrait
ça fonctionne déjà trs bien oui
malheureusement mais là c'est pour des
raisons
économi bien tout à fait tout à fait je
suis sur le terrain pour défendre
l'apprentissage serai la première à le
défendre donc deuxième chose oui sur le
le le le service civique et bien écoutez
moi ça me semble un dispositif très
intéressant d'ailleurs il fonctionne
actuellement il fonctionne sauf qu'il
faut mettre un peu plus de moyens
puisque aujourd'hui pour C jeunes qui se
présente uniquement un est retenu or il
y a une très forte demande donc
sincèrement est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est une réponse à aux questions une
rép c'est une des réponses très sincè r
peti répse aujourd'hui effectivement
beaucoup de jeunes demandent parce que
ils n'ont rien d'autre donc ils
demandent ils savent qu'il y a 500 et
quelques euros et cetera à gagner et
bien évidemment ils en ont besoin
effectivement ils n'ont pas et CHK cette
semaine l'a bien dit on n'a pas pu
satisfaire toutes les demandes donc on
va demain pouvoir satisfaire toutes les
demandes et bien je dit d'abord on n'est
pas sûr d'y arriver mais ça sera au
détriment des associations par exemple
qui vont effectivement Pr des jeunes
comme ça donc de l'emploi dans les
associations de l'emploi dans les
services effectivement comme vous le
disiez et d' la personne et là ce sont
des métier qui nécessite une
qualification donc on peut pas y rentrer
comme ça du jour au lendemain viens mon
petit tu vas aller aider la personne
âgée et cetera il faut développer
l'emploi dans ce pays avant tout et on
fait tout le contraire de ce qu'il
faudrait faire pour le développer on
détruit des
organismes on donne la parole à CHR par
parce que Marine Le Pen a proposé de
remettre en place le service militaire
absolument et donc François Hollande a
proposé un service civique universel qui
ne prend que le relais du service
civique déjà lancé par Nicolas Sarkozy
en 2010 mais non mais qui est destiné à
des missions éducative associative c'est
du flan ah bon non c'est un service oui
oui au rétablissement d'un service
national mais d'abord il faudrait
commencer par ne pas réduire le budget
de de l'armée qui était la variable
d'ajustement budget année après année
depuis 30 ans il faut donner au aux
professionnels les moyens de de
d'accomplir leur métier et puis après
oui il quand je pense par exemple
l'armée l'armée dit qu'elle est de toute
façon pas les moyensorganiser un service
national en centraafrique nous avons
envoyé 2000 2000 soldats il en faudrait
10000 écoutez ce qui se dit dans sur les
réseaux
sociaux les soldats qui reviennent ils
sont épuisés démotivés il quittent l'
c'est service national don je parle
d'abord du budget de la de la Défense
nationale qu'il faut sanctiser etug
c'est pas ça la question c'est est-ce
qu'un service national peut influerou la
cohésion sociale du Pay oui absolument
et il faut rétablir un service national
mais sur la base du volontariat avec une
sélection effectivement qui donnerait
d'ailleurs droit peut-être à être
prioritaire pour la fonction publique
ensuite qui serait un réajuste enfin un
approfondissement des connaissances
générale et puis une instruction
militaire oui pour afin de constituer
une garde nationale qui soit suppléti de
qui soit suppletif de la gendarmerie
Suiss une minute pour que dise quelque
chose avant la
fin s PL s PLA s vous PL je reg je regr
parler il vaut mieux il vaut mieux
prévenir que que guérir dans
l'urgence je regrette que la
conscription je regrette que la
conscription a effectivement été
abandonnée c'est c'est vraiment dommage
pour en particulier effectivement pour
cette cohésion qui qui intervenait au
moment décision de Jacques Chirac que
que que voilà que je regrette je vous le
dis très sincèrement aujourd'hui le
service civique d'ailleurs c'est amusant
parce que c'est seule c'est la seule
proposition concrète du président de la
République jeudi La Seu c'est même pas
SC parce que dans dans les journ on
voyait déjà cette proposition j'ajoute
d'ailleurs que il y a une mission
parlementaire aujourd'hui qui va
permettre d'avancer sur ce sujet de vous
couper parce que c'est le journal de
midi dans 5 secondes on reprend après on
reprend après 5 minutes d'information
mid onrouve juste
après